monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
spéciale messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
l'insécurité que rencontre nos
concitoyens sur Internet sapent leur
confiance dans la transition numérique
tous les Français sont concernés tous
constatent les désordres qui
s'accumulent dans l'espace numérique et
en particulier les Français les plus
vulnérables
les Français les plus modestes les plus
âgés qui sont les victimes privilégiées
des cybercriminels nos enfants bien sûr
qui sont exposés de manière très précoce
à des contenus inappropriés nos
entreprises que la loi du plus fort
place sous le Joux et la dépendance des
géants du numérique et notre démocratie
qui est soumise au coût de butoir
incessants des professionnels de l'un
des informations face à ces désordres la
France agit résolument depuis cinq ans à
tous les niveaux au niveau national avec
des initiatives parlementaires qui nous
ont permis de progresser nos matières
notamment en matière de lutte contre la
désinformation de protection des mineurs
en ligne de lutte contre le
cyber-harcèlement au niveau européen j'y
reviendrai brièvement avec deux
règlements majeurs adoptés l'année
dernière sous président français de
l'Union européenne au niveau
international en Suisse avec des
initiatives
partie prise par le Président de la
République et qui ont contribué à
éveiller la conscience mondiale sur ce
problème de notre siècle ce projet de
loi qui vous est proposé d'examiner
aujourd'hui poursuit le même objectif
celui d'instaurer un ordre public
numérique et de créer des protections
nouvelles pour nos concitoyens nos
enfants nos entreprises et collectivités
et notre démocratie il s'est formé à
partir de trois affluents le premier de
ces affluences ce sont ces deux
règlements européens adoptés l'année
dernière sous présidence française de
l'Union européenne
qui sont d'applications directes mais
qui nécessite que nous modifions notre
droit pour qu'ils puissent correctement
s'appliquer dans notre pays le premier
de ces règlements le Règlement sur les
services numériques fait entrer les
grandes plateformes de réseaux sociaux
dans l'air de la responsabilité en leur
imposant des obligations de modération
en leur apposant d'analyser et de
corriger le risque systémique qu'ils
font peser sur la santé de leurs
utilisateurs mais aussi sur la sécurité
publique et les événements récents ont
confirmé à quel point il était
nécessaire et urgent qu'un tel réglement
puisse intervenir et puis ce règlement
impose des interdictions nouvelles comme
celles par exemple de faire de la
publicité ciblée sur les mineurs
deuxième règlement le Règlement sur les
marchés numériques qui vient rétablir
l'équité commerciale et mettre fin à un
certain nombre d'abus de position
dominante dans l'économie numérique
en définissant 26 pratiques
anti-concurentielles qui seront
désormais interdites dans l'Union
européenne
l'auto préférence le fait pour un une
entreprise du numérique d'utiliser des
données collectées sur l'un de ses
services au profit d'un autre ou du
fonctionnement d'un autre de ses
services l'interopérabilité entre les
messageries etc le premier affluent
c'est celui-ci la mise en oeuvre de ces
deux règlements européens majeurs le
deuxième affluence ce sont vos travaux
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
travaux parlementaires qui ont porté
notamment sur l'exposition des mineurs
au contenu pornographique et je pense
évidemment
au rapport de Laurence Rossignol
Laurence Cohen Annick Billon et
Alexandre fontinp je pense également au
rapport qui a été rendu par Amel gacquet
à Franck motoget Sophie prima sur la
souveraineté numérique ou plus récemment
au rapport de la mission d'in sur le
règlement sur les données de Catherine
Morin de Saïd Florence blatrix compta et
d'André gatelin nous avons ni plus ni
moins mesdames et messieurs et sénateurs
que fait que reprendre certaines des
propositions qui figurer dans ces
rapports et qu'il me paraissait
important que nous puissions mettre en
œuvre au plus vite troisième affluent
les consultations que nous avons menées
sous l'égide du Conseil national de la
refondation et qui ont inspiré certaines
des mesures que vous retrouvez dans ce
projet de loi notamment en ce qui
concerne la lutte contre le
cyber-harcèlement et donc en définitive
des protections nouvelles que je veux
décrire en quelques mots devant vous en
soulignant les apports décisifs apportés
par les travaux de la commission
spéciale qui s'est rassemblée la semaine
dernière pour examiner le texte
au chapitre de la protection de nos
concitoyens trois mesures fortes la
première c'est le filtre
anti-arnac ou en tout cas la base légale
de ce filtre entièrement qui servira de
rempart contre les campagnes de SMS et
de mails frauduleux nous avons tous reçu
un mail du compte personnel de ou un sms
du compte personnel de formation ou de
la sécurité sociale nous avons tous
hésité à cliquer et à vrai dire mesdames
et messieurs et sénateurs ce sont 18
millions de nos concitoyens qui l'année
dernière ont été victimes de la
cybercriminalité dont la moitié ce sont
vu soustraire de l'argent au passage
et évidemment ce sont nos concitoyens
les plus fragiles les plus éloignés du
numérique qui sont les plus susceptibles
de se faire ainsi aspirer dans la
spirale infernale de l'usurpation
d'identité dont ils mettent parfois plus
d'une décennie pour pouvoir se sortir il
nous faut donc avec ce filtre
entièrement coupé le mâle à la racine et
dévitaliser le commerce de ces pirates
qui ont décidé de faire de nos
smartphones de nos tablettes
l'instrument de leur raquette deuxième
menu mesure une peine complémentaire de
bannissement des réseaux sociaux pour
une période de six mois portait à un an
en cas de récidive pour les personnes
reconnues coupables de fait de
cyber-harcèlement ainsi que d'autres
faits de violence en ligne le
cyber-harcèlement se propage comme une
traînée de poudre sur les réseaux
sociaux les responsables une minorité
d'internautes qui se comporte parfois
comme des chefs de meute qui désignent
des victimes à la vindicte de leur
communauté et qui déclenche sur ces
victimes des raids de violence et de
haine avec cette mesure qui est inspirée
de la mesure d'interdiction de la peine
complémentaire d'interdiction de stade
nous voulons
couper là aussi le mal à la racine en
privant ces chefs de meute de
l'orchestre de résonance en confisquant
leur notoriété et en rendant impossible
la récidive et je veux saluer les
travaux du rapporteur Loïc Hervé qui a
permis d'étendre cette peine
complémentaire dans un certain nombre de
dimensions qui permettront au juge qui
décidera de s'en saisir de faire en
sorte que cette question de la récidive
sur les réseaux sociaux soit du Mans
traité troisième mesure de protection de
nos concitoyens un régime encadrant les
nouveaux jeux en ligne fondés sur la
technologie sur les technologies du web
3 il s'agit là de créer les conditions
pour que ces activités puissent se
développer en France tout en assurant le
plus haut niveau de protection au mineur
mais aussi de garantir la lutte
effective contre le blanchiment et la
lutte contre le terrorisme et de ce
point de vue là je veux remercier
féliciter le rapporteur Patrick chaises
d'avoir su rédiger en dur la disposition
qui définit l'expérimentation pendant
une durée de trois ans dans laquelle ces
activités vont pouvoir se déployer avec
un certain nombre de garanties les
entourants là où la copie initiale du
gouvernement il faut bien le confesser
consistait en une habilitation à les
différer par Ordinance donc je le
remercier le rapporteur pour son travail
au chapitre de la protection des mineurs
deux mesures fortes la première consiste
à donner à l'arc comme le pouvoir
d'ordonner le blocage le des
référencements et des amendes
dissuasives à l'encontre des sites
pornographiques qui ne vérifieront pas
l'âge des utilisateurs grâce à la
proposition enfin grâce à la loi du 20
du 30 juillet 2020 l'obligation est
faite aussi de pornographique de
vérifier l'âge de leurs utilisateurs ça
n'est toujours pas fait à l'heure
actuelle une procédure est en cours
devant le tribunal judiciaire de Paris
qui rendra son verdict vendredi
c'est-à-dire dans trois jours
constatant les délais de cette procédure
le rapport des sénatrices a ouvert un
certain nombre de pistes complémentaires
dont cette faculté donnée à l'arcom
d'ordonnées en quelques semaines le
blocage des sites pornographiques pour
les affaires à venir et effectivement
pour les affaires à venir cette
disposition nous permettra d'aller
beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup plus fort
autre mesure de protection des enfants
une peine d'un an d'emprisonnement et
250 000 euros d'amende pour les
hébergeurs qui ne retireront pas les
contenus pédoporn graphique qui leur
sont signalés par les services de la
police et de la gendarmerie en moins de
24 heures à l'image de la sanction qui
est prévue pour le non retrait par les
hébergeurs des contenus terroristes je
veux rappeler que l'année dernière
74000 contenus pédopornographiques ont
été signalés aux hébergeurs par les
services de la gendarmerie et de la
police il faut donc assortir cette
obligation de retrait d'une sanction et
c'est ce qui est prévu par le texte deux
mesures ensuite de protection de nos
entreprises et de nos collectivités
d'abord pour nos entreprises
l'encadrement des avoir commerciaux
l'interopérabilité et l'interdiction des
frais de transfert sur le marché de
l'info nuagique c'est-à-dire sur le
marché du cloud c'est un marché qui est
extrêmement concentré entre les mains
d'une poignée d'acteurs qui tiennent nos
entreprises dans un lien de dépendance
et d'assujettissement là aussi il faut
en finir avec la loi du plus fort ça a
été proposé par un certain nombre de
rapports du Sénat nous y avons été très
sens avec Bruno Le Maire puisque la
souveraineté en matière de numérique et
de Cloud est une priorité pour nous et
vous trouverez donc dans ce projet de
loi affiné par les travaux de la
commission spéciale des mesures qui nous
permettront de rendre leur liberté et
donc un peu d'air aux entreprises de
France et puis pour les collectivités
une base de données unique pour leur
permettre de mieux réguler l'activité
des meublés de tourisme une
expérimentation s'est tenue ces
dernières années qui a associé cinq
collectivités et cinq plateformes de
location avec le projet de loi nous
proposons de pérenniser cette
expérimentation et que les collectivités
pour pouvoir vérifier la bonne
application du droit et en particulier
la limite des 128 par an puisse pouvoir
se tourner vers un interlocuteur unique
de manière à vérifier que les règles et
en particulier celles des 120 nuées sont
bien appliquées sur leur territoire
enfin je voudrais souligner une mesure
de protection de notre démocratie avec
le pouvoir donné à l'arcom de mettre en
demeure
et d'ordonner le blocage des sites qui
diffuseront des médias frappés par des
sanctions telles que celles que l'Union
européenne a pris à l'encontre de RT
France et de Spoutnik la désinformation
est d'une des menaces les plus lourdes
qui pèsent sur notre démocratie les
ennemis de la démocratie dévoient la
liberté d'expression pour instiller dans
le débat public le mensonge avec cette
mesure nous
compléterons notre arsenal de lutte
contre la désinformation
ce projet de loi jeu je l'avais dit
lorsque je l'ai présenté devant la
commission spéciale à vocation à être
enrichie et renforcée
au Parlement et singulièrement au Sénat
je serai pour ma part attentif à ce que
nous veillons collectivement à ne pas
franchir deux lignes rouges la première
de ces lignes rouges c'est de veiller à
ce que les compromis que la France
apportait au niveau européen et qui ont
donné lieu aux règlements sur les
services numériques au Règlement sur les
marchés numériques soit respectés par ce
par ce texte dont nous allons débattre
ensemble il s'agit donc de compromis la
France n'a pas pu obtenir tout ce
qu'elle aurait voulu mais le fait que ce
soit que ce que ce soit des compromis
européens leur donnent toute leur force
et c'est effectivement en faisant levier
du marché unique européen que nous avons
pu ainsi obtenir un certain nombre de
concessions et que les sanctions
associées à au non respect de ces
règlements seront d'une sévérité
suffisamment dissuasive pour que les
géants du numérique modifient une bonne
fois pour toutes leurs comportement la
deuxième ligne rouge c'est que
s'agissant de tous ces désordres que
nous constatons au quotidien dans
l'espace numérique il est parfois
tentant de vouloir y mettre fin de
manière de manière d'une manière qui en
freine à certaines des libertés
fondamentales sur lesquelles reposent
notre fonctionnement démocratique la
liberté d'expression la liberté
d'information et la liberté de
communication il nous faudra dans nos
débats discerner pour faire en sorte que
vos propositions et que les nôtres se
tiennent bien entre ces deux lignes
rouges le respect des compromis obtenu
par la France au niveau européen et le
respect des libertés fondamentales sur
lesquelles reposent notre démocratie je
compte évidemment sur le le Sénat pour
enrichir et renforcer ce texte qui
poursuivra ensuite son chemin vers
l'Assemblée nationale et je vous
remercie par avance pour la qualité de
nos échanges madame la Présidente
messieurs rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les sén